[Music]
what's up everybody michael here it's
been nearly a decade since the most
infamous restaurant review of all time
it included classic zingers like how the
blue watermelon margarita tastes like
some combination of radiator fluid and
formaldehyde and the one that asks why
is one of the few things on your menu
that can be eaten without fear or regret
called a roasted pork bon me when it
resembles that item about as much as you
resemble emily dickinson the review in
question eviscerated guys american
kitchen and bar owned by guy fieri the
review slash assassination attempt was
penned by new york times restaurant
critic pete wells when it came out in
2012 fieri had already been a food
network star for six years with several
seasons of guy's big bite and diners
drive-ins and dives under his belt he
also owned four successful restaurants
today diners drive-ins and dives is in
its 35th season that's a great win
guys grocery games has enjoyed almost 30
seasons and fieri's face has graced
scores of other food network shows and
there are plenty of fiery haters out
there writing them off is all bombast
and then welles's words a representation
of going insane and don't forget the
time anthony bourdain wondered how does
guy fieri d douche
but despite the haters fieri's star
continues to shine brighter than a
kitchen grease fire is this guy just the
result of what happens when a can of red
bull in a jar of hot sauce make a baby
can this guy yes this guy actually teach
us a lot about the cultural function of
food let's find out in this wisecrack
edition guy fieri deep or dumb it's no
secret the guy fieri is a busy dude and
as the title of his flagship show diners
drive-ins and dives suggest fieri is a
champion of food that's generally
considered lowbrow it is seriously too
legit to quit though and because he is
genuinely psyched to eat a jalapeno
pepper popper sandwich made by an
unknown chef it's easy for critics to
write him off as a bombastic goofball
that puts him in stark contrast with his
fellow food network stars who posture as
serious chefs or bastions of fine dining
like the casual culinary queen of east
hampton ina garten or the ginger master
of the restaurant kitchen mr robert
william flay but fieri is a long time
restaurateur in his own right and his
recipes have a consistent ethos firmly
rooted in a lack of concern over
traditional food preparations and a
passion for inventive culinary fusion
aside from showing you the fiery tattoo
over my heart it is difficult to
overstate what a singular presence he is
in the celebrity chef landscape but to
truly understand the taste of flavortown
it's important to assess him in the
context of our national history of
celebrity chefs america wasn't always
obsessed with watching people cook
outrageous things on tv in fact the act
of eating in mainstream post-world war
ii america was all about convenience and
economy unless you were lucky enough to
have a bomb-ass italian nona to serve
you up some rigatoni as french chef
jacques papan described in his memoir in
america food was sustenance full stop
that meant lots of cheap highly
processed eats but the arrival of french
cooking in mainstream america would
conjure a new cultural preoccupation
with things like food quality freshness
and seasonality the first big american
celebrity chef was julia child who
brought her training at the cordon bleu
back home to teach her audience that
french dishes tasted better than cream
of mushroom soup based casseroles her
act was revelatory showing that fancy
cooking techniques like mincing a
mirepoix or deboning a duck weren't just
for the professionals also she invented
shark repellent for the navy seriously
google it after her show the french chef
debuted in 1963 public appetite for food
tv mushroomed and from the mid-80s to
the mid-90s foodie culture became a
mainstay of american life coinciding
with the reagan era and the yuppie boom
this eventually led to the creation of
the food network founded in 1993 it
boasted hosts like emerald lagasse
jacques papan and robin leach and by the
time the channel was popular enough to
host the next food network star its
stable of celebrity chefs represented
something very specific sure they each
had their own personality bam bam and
areas of expertise but they were unified
in a vibe that dominates the network and
celebrity chef culture to this day they
were seasoned experienced and focused on
elevating the dishes they were making
sometimes that means staying loyal to
the traditional preparation methods of
addition sometimes it means adding an
unexpected fancy twist i'd like to take
something really traditional and do it
with a twist and i thought wouldn't it
be fun to take the croutons and put it
on the outside or as spectacular
foodscapes authors josie johnson and
michael goodman would put it food media
frames and mediates what foodscapes
could and should be how they could and
should operate and for whom they could
and should work they communicate
specific food instructions via recipes
but they also project powerful images of
what constitutes a good meal a worthy
home cook and a celebrated chef that is
to say food influencers set the bar for
home cooking and the rest of us just try
to capture their vibes in this context
of good meals and celebrated chefs it's
no wonder that the discourse around guy
fieri has remained spicy we live in a
culture that assigns moral value to food
as a result good food can mean anything
from healthy to fancy to healthy fancy
and this is where fieri breaks the
jell-o mole the majority of the food he
showcases is neither low in cholesterol
or high in its opinion of itself truffle
oil is supplanted by donkey sauce and we
think that's a crucial part of his
appeal his only criteria for a good meal
are if it tastes oh that's ridiculous
and of course as far as that celebrated
chef thing goes we have that infamous
review among many others to cast
aspersion upon its credentials but the
discourse around fiery doesn't stop
there scholar emily conchoir noted in
her book diners dudes and diets that as
of spring 2020 the food site eater had
published more features about fieti than
any other big name chef be it anthony
bourdain david chang or anybody else and
these posts generated more than twice as
many comments than any other chefs
so why the disparity we think it comes
down to the cultural context guy fieri
is operating within it's all fun and
guys grocery games for the hoi polloi
who think fieti is a cool down to earth
dude they'd like to get a beer with but
that's precisely why it's so easy for
critics to dunk on him he's easily
defined as part of what scholar dwight
mcdonald would call the mass culture or
its more sinister moniker mass cult
that's essentially a commercialized and
totally artificial culture popularized
by the mass media mascult exists in
opposition to what mcdonald calls high
culture which he characterizes as more
of the formal things you'll learn about
in school like shakespeare or the viola
in the case of food that means high
culture is culinary school whereas mass
cult is home cooking or picking up
skills in a diner kitchen and while both
the mass cult and high culture can be
wildly popular among the great republic
mcdonald argued way back in 1960 in the
united states the demands of the
audience which has changed from a small
body of connoisseurs into a large body
of ignoramuses have become the chief
criteria of success
this was an exceedingly rude way of
saying that taste had been democratized
and thus was driven by the consumer
demands of the masses
that's how mcdonald's the restaurant not
the scholar has managed to serve
hundreds of billions of big macs without
serving a mick ratatouille even once and
when applying this framework to
television food celebrity culture it
explains why the food network airs so
many hours of fiery content he is
exactly what the spectator wants in
other words fieri has some big let
people like what they like energy
however the irony is that while guy
fieri himself might be a product of
masculine he spends many of his
on-screen hours highlighting restaurants
owned not by millionaire celebrity chefs
or backed by groups of financiers but
independent local spots owned by
families and food-obsessed
non-celebrities the implicit message
seems to be even in parts of the country
dominated by chain restaurants and big
box stores there are still amazing
unique meals to be had if you're willing
to find them yet despite being an easy
target guy fieri staunchly refuses to be
anything other than what he is someone
who loves food his family and the
unassuming mom and pop joints that to
him are quintessentially american and
when he tries their signature dishes
whether it's a traditional take on a
club sandwich or a modern update on
ramen he's not trying to change them or
upgrade their fanciness or make them
ready for a photo shoot he takes them
exactly as they are and champions their
specific flavors and often their unique
flavor profiles and while there are
plenty of classic chili dogs and
homemade twinkies to be had on triple d
it's in a lot of ways remarkably
inclusive as far as the show is
concerned any food made in america is
quintessentially american especially
when those cuisines originated from
other countries greek favorites like
hand-rolled beef and filled grape leaves
in recent years you're more likely to
see an interesting take on vietnamese
korean or mexican food on triple d than
you are a new iteration of wings or
burgers a greek family making tacos in
texas and bonus points for foods that
are mashups of different cultures like
pastrami tacos or duck confit enchiladas
that's a situation that fieri loves to
describe as ridiculous
ridiculously good fieri's staked his
brand on an attitude of i'm no better
than you
we just all love food food is the
greatest common denominator who that
meat tender flaky pull a party super
hotty smoldery bernie mouth this is a
crucial difference between him and most
other food celebrities on triple d his
expertise is held in reserve he doesn't
make the rules and he's not here to
correct anyone and while we might not
think of fiery as overtly philosophical
his sensibility towards food culture
shares something with scottish
philosopher and legendary edinboro bar
patron david hume who said indulge your
passion for science but let your science
be human and such as may have a direct
reference to action and society be a
philosopher but amidst all your
philosophy be still a man
for hume this meant that deep and
speculative thought was important but so
was experiencing life being social and
having fun for him philosophy was never
meant to be at the expense of relating
to everyday life and more bluntly being
a good hang and part of the reason
fieri's approach works is because he
never gets distracted by the more
conceptual and intellectual aspects of
modern food culture he's mostly there to
chill and chow down fieri's version of
hume's quote might be be a chef but not
at the expense of being a down to earth
dude sure while he's there he talks
about these supposedly lowbrow foods in
a highbrow way and he makes it clear he
knows his way around a kitchen without
acting like he owns the place and it's
precisely this approach that puts his
culinary skills somewhat in the
background so the viewer can fully revel
in the sensory experience of eating a
falafel waffle with him fieri's
restaurant experience doesn't distract
from the joy of eating he doesn't roll
into these smaller businesses to throw
his ego around unlike another chef we
know
holy crap
rubber tasteless that's going straight
to the trash
and he's even hella humble it's a great
place you got great people this is the
real diner feel so congratulations while
he might get a lot of flack for his own
brand most of what he's done on triple d
is give a massive amount of promotion to
local spots he really believes in as far
as fiery is concerned everyone he meets
is an expert when it comes to making
their signature dishes and he has to
show deference to their recipes because
fieti himself has built a reputation on
creating his own unconventional menu
items he's not a pretentious culinary
scold he picked up most of his skills
working in actual restaurants he's
positioned as a self-made man and this
bolsters his public appeal because
americans love a bootstrapping narrative
all of these factors combined make us
wonder if guy fieri is the living
breathing embodiment of the ideal
american indeed fieri's devotion to
welcoming foods of all kinds into his
show's vision of america suggests that
he may be our true populist king as cook
and author julia tursian wrote for lucky
peach when it comes to visibility and
inclusiveness diners drive-ins and dives
succeeds food allows the show to
highlight inclusivity without being
about inclusivity and yet for segments
of american culture that would still
call indian food exotic fieti appeals
nonetheless as julia moscone wrote in
the new york times he has a sarah
palin-like ability to reach americans
who feel left behind by the nation's
cultural or in his case culinary elite
except of course fieri has never claimed
the ability to see a foreign nation from
outside of his northern california home
if most american celebrity chefs teach
people how to cook elevated food by say
adding french techniques fieri seeks to
celebrate the american food that chefs
are already cooking now if yeti famously
keeps mum about his political opinions
though he'll do arguably political acts
like fundraising nearly 25 million
dollars on behalf of unemployed
restaurant workers or cooking meals for
volunteers fighting california wildfires
as matt schimkowicz put it in the av
club whether you read his actions as
philanthropic or socialist or the end of
food culture as we know it guy fits the
bill he shows up puts on a show and
leaves it to his audience to define who
he is to them and indeed fiery is able
to cash in on his keen insight into the
broader american psyche by being
everything and anything to everyone and
anyone regardless of background
political affiliation or access to flame
printed shirts there's plenty of
problems with america but ultimately
fieri represents all the best parts of
what the country claims to value
inclusivity joy and on fire out of
bounds kicking gangster bomb flavor
morsels and that in our opinion is
actually kinda surprisingly weak can't
believe we're about to say this
deep you hear what i'm saying but what
do you guys think is guy fieri the
ultimate embodiment of american ideals
or is he just a burger loving dude who
single-handedly kept the hair bleach
industry afloat let us know in the
comments hit the subscribe button like
you're throwing too much sauce on the
meat and don't forget to ring that bell
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our new
exclusive perks on patreon and as always
thanks for watching
later
[Music]